what are some cool synthetic organisms
that you you think about you dream about
when you think about embodied mind what
do you imagine what do you hope to build
yeah on a practical level what I really
hope to do is to gain enough of an
understanding of the embodied
intelligence of the organs and tissues
such that we can achieve a radically
different regenerative medicine so that
we can say basically and I I think about
it as um you know in terms of like okay
can you what's the what's the uh uh
what's the goal kind of uh and and end
game for this whole thing to me the end
game is something that you would call an
anatomical compiler so the idea is you
would sit down in front of the computer
and you would draw the the body or the
organ that you wanted not not molecular
details but like here this is what I
want I want a six-legged uh you know
frog with a propeller on top or I want I
want a heart that looks like this or I
want a leg that looks like this and what
it would do if we knew what we were
doing is
put out uh it could convert that
anatomical description into a set of
stimuli that would have to be given to
cells to convince them to build exactly
that thing right I probably won't live
to see it but I think it's achievable
and I think what that if if we can have
that then that is basically the solution
to all of medicine except for infectious
disease so birth defects right traumatic
injury cancer aging degenerative disease
if we knew how to tell cells what to
build all of those things go away so
those things go away and the um positive
feedback spiral of economic costs where
all of the advances are increasingly
more heroic and expensive interventions
of a sinking ship when you're like 90
and then and and so on right all of that
goes away because basically instead of
trying to fix you up as you as you
degrade you you
um you progressively regenerate you know
you apply the regenerative medicine
early before things degrade so I think
that that'll have massive economic
impact over what we're trying to do now
which is not at all you know sustain
animal and uh and that that's what I
hope I hope that I hope that we get it
so so to me yes the xenobots will be
doing useful things cleaning up the
environment cleaning out you know your
or you know your joints and all that
kind of stuff but more important than
that I think we can use these uh
synthetic systems to try to understand
to to develop a science of detecting and
manipulating the goals of collective
intelligences of cells specifically for
regenerative medicine and then sort of
beyond that if we you know sort of think
further beyond that what I hope is that
kind of like what you said all of this
drives a reconsideration of how we
formulate um ethical Norms because this
old school so so so in the olden days
what you could do is obviously we were
confronted with something you you could
you could tap on it right and if you
heard a metallic clanging sound you'd
said ah fine right so you could conclude
it was made in a factory I could take it
apart I can do whatever right if you did
that and you got you know sort of a
squishy uh kind of warm sensation you'd
say I need to be you know more or less
nice to it and whatever that's not going
to be feasible it was never really
feasible but it was good enough because
we didn't have any we didn't know any
better that needs to go and I think that
uh by by breaking down those artificial
barriers someday we can try to build a a
system of of ethical Norms that does not
rely on these completely contingent
facts of of our Earthly history but on
something much much deeper that you know
really um takes takes agency and and the
capacity to suffer and all that takes
that seriously
the capacity to suffer and the Deep
questions I would ask of a system is can
I eat it and can I have sex with it
um which is the the two fundamental
tests of Again The Human Condition
uh so I can basically do what Dali does
that's in the in in the physical space
so print out like a 3D print a Pepe the
frog with a propeller head
propeller hat
uh is the is the Dream well I want to
yes and no I mean I want to get away
from the 3D printing thing because that
will be available for some things much
earlier I mean we can already do
bladders and ears and things like that
because it's micro level control right
when you 3D print you are in charge of
where every cell goes and for some
things that you know for like this thing
they had that I think 20 years ago or
maybe a little earlier than that you
could do that see I would like to have
says the dolly part where you provide a
few words yeah and it generates a
painting so here you say I want a frog
with these features and then it would go
direct a complex biological system to
construct something like that yeah the
main magic would be I mean I think from
from looking at Dali and so on it looks
like the first part is kind of solved
now where you go from from the words to
the image like that seems more or less
solved the next step is really hard this
is what keeps things like crispr and
genomic editing and so on it's good this
is what limits all the except
uh uh impacts for for gender medicine
because going back to okay this is the
knee joint that I want or this is the
eye that I want
now what genes do I edit to make that
happen right going back in that
direction is really hard so instead of
that it's going to be okay I understand
how to motivate cells to build
particular structures can I rewrite the
memory of what they think they're
supposed to be building such that then I
can you know take my hands off the wheel
and let them let them do their thing so
some of that is experiment but some of
that maybe AI can help too just like
with protein folding this is exactly the
problem that protein folding uh in in
the most simple
medium tried and has solved with Alpha
fold which is how does the sequence of
letters result in this three-dimensional
shape and you have to
um I guess it didn't solve it because
you have to
if you say I want this shape how do I
then have a sequence of letters
yeah the reverse engineering stuff is
really tricky it is I think I think
where where and we're doing some of this
now is is to uh use AI to try and uh
build actionable models of the
intelligence of the cellular collectives
so try to help us to help us gain models
that that
um and and we've had some success in
this so we did something like this for
um uh for you know for repairing uh
birth defects of the brain in frog we've
done some of this for I'm normalizing
melanoma uh where you can really start
to use AI to make models of how would I
impact this thing if I wanted to given
all the complexities right and and given
all the uh the the the controls that
that it knows how to do